digamos que están planeando una fiesta y
como todos sabemos una fiesta necesita
un número apropiado de monos en este
momento tienen 10 monos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 pero les gustaría tener 18 monos
entonces cuántos monos más necesitan
para tener esos 18 monos y los invito a
pausar el vídeo para que traten de
resolver esto antes de que yo lo haga
recuerden que la meta aquí es tener 18
monos que sabemos del número 18 en el
número 18 tenemos un 1 en la posición de
las decenas estas son decenas que
literalmente nos representa una decena
y luego este 8 representa 8 unidades
unidades
+ 8 unidades y todo esto es lo mismo que
una vez en es igual a 10 + 8 unidades 10
+ 8
si empezamos con 10 monos que es el
número de monos que tenemos cuantos más
necesitamos para tener 18 si empezamos
con 10 necesitamos 8 más para llegar a
18 y lo podemos verificar visualmente si
queremos déjenme copiar uno de estos
monos lo copio y tengo que llegar a 1811
s
y 18 cuántos monos agregamos bueno pues
empezamos con estos 10 que tenemos aquí
arriba y los voy a poner en un
rectángulo y vemos que tenemos aquí un
grupo de 10 o sea una decena y aquí voy
a escribir el 10 y luego pusimos ocho
monos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y 8
empezamos con 10 sumamos 8 monos más
para obtener 18
y para repasar una vez más cómo pensamos
en este número 18 como una decena y 8
unidades que es lo mismo que 10 más 8